el 25 de mayo de 2020 el policía directo
a bing mató a george freud un ciudadano
afroestadounidense al asfixiarlo por más
de nueve minutos con su rodilla
las imágenes conmocionaron a minnesota y
pronto comenzaron las protestas la
violencia policial y el racismo fueron
el objeto de la ira de miles de personas
durante días y las principales ciudades
del país comenzaron a marchar en memoria
de floyd algo que tambaleó la política
estadounidense y llegó a las puertas de
la casa blanca george flores vengas a
ver la memoria de georg floyd está
siendo deshonrado por alborotadores
saqueadores y anarquistas la violencia y
el vandalismo están siendo liderados por
antifaz y otros grupos radicales de
izquierda que están aterrorizando
inocentes y destruyendo trabajos
jobs donald trump fue muy crítico con
las protestas y sacó a la guardia
nacional en varias ciudades para sofocar
las pero la ola de manifestaciones
alentada por el movimiento black lives
matter traspasó fronteras y llenó las
calles de cientos de ciudades del mundo
como parís roma o londres
estas personas no exigían solamente
justicia para ellos floyd
también querían justicia histórica y
estatuas de esclavistas como edward
koleston cayeron el 9 de junio georges
floyd recibió un gran homenaje durante
su funeral un acto que sirvió para
reivindicar su figura y exigir justicia
y una reforma profunda de lo que
consideran racismo institucional
quiero justicia para mi hermano mi
hermano mayor todos lo recordarán en
todo el mundo él va a cambiar el mundo
en seis word
el agente derecho bin encara el juicio
acusado por asesinato en segundo grado y
homicidio involuntario y a un movimiento
que espera una condena ejemplarizante
que siente precedente
[Música]